Y si todo estaba allí,
incluso los orgánicos,
quizá la vida había comenzado.
Curiosity también perforó esa tierra roja
y extrajo otro material.
Y nos entusiasmamos mucho cuando vimos eso.
Porque Marte no era rojo,
era un material gris,
es gris Marte.
Lo llevamos al vehículo,
lo examinamos,
y ¿adivinen qué?
Encontramos orgánicos...
carbono, hidrógeno, oxígeno,
nitrógeno, fósforo, azufre;
todo eso estaba allí.
Así que Marte en su pasado,
con una gran cantidad de agua,
quizá hace mucho tiempo,
pudo haber tenido vida,
pudo haber tenido esa chispa,
pudo haber crecido.
Y ¿la vida sigue ahí?
No lo sabemos.
Pero hace unos años
empezamos a ver una serie de cráteres.
Durante el verano,
aparecerían líneas oscuras por las laderas de esos cráteres.
Cuanto más miramos,
cuanto más cráteres veíamos,
más de estas características aparecían.
Ahora conocemos más de una docena de ellos.
Hace unos meses, el cuento de hadas se hizo realidad.
Anunciamos al mundo que sabemos lo que son estas rayas.
Es agua líquida.
Estos cráteres están corriendo durante el verano.
El agua líquida fluye por esos cráteres.
Entonces, ¿qué vamos a hacer ahora...
ahora que vemos el agua?
Bueno, nos dice que Marte tiene todos los ingredientes necesarios para la vida.
En su pasado tenía quizá dos tercios de su hemisferio norte...
había un océano.
Fluye agua ahora mismo.
Agua líquida en su superficie.
Hay orgánicos.
Tiene todas las condiciones adecuadas.
Entonces, ¿qué vamos a hacer ahora?
Pondremos en marcha una serie de misiones
para iniciar esa búsqueda de vida en Marte.
Y ahora es más atractivo que nunca antes.
Conforme avanzamos hacia el sistema solar,
esta es la diminuta luna Encélado.
Esto no es lo que llamamos la zona habitable tradicional,
esta zona alrededor del sol.
Esto es de mucho más lejos.
Este objeto debería ser hielo sobre un núcleo de silicato.
Pero ¿qué encontramos?
Cassini estuvo allí desde el 2006,
y después de un par de años miró hacia atrás tras volar por Encélado
y nos sorprendió a todos.
Encélado arroja láminas de agua hacia el sistema solar
y salpica hacia la luna.
Qué fabuloso ambiente.
Cassini hace solo unos meses también voló sobre el penacho,
y midió partículas de silicato.
¿De dónde viene el sílice?
Debe venir del fondo del océano.
La energía de las mareas es generada por Saturno,
tirando y apretando a esta luna,
está derritiendo ese hielo,
creando un océano.
Pero también le hace eso al núcleo.
Lo único que podemos pensar
aquí en la Tierra como analogía...
son las fuentes hidrotermales.
Las fuentes hidrotermales profundas del océano fueron descubiertas en 1977.
Los oceanógrafos se sorprendieron por completo.
Y ahora hay miles de estos por debajo del océano.
¿Qué encontramos?
Los oceanógrafos, cuando miran estas fuentes hidrotermales,
ven que están rebosantes de vida,
independientemente de si el agua es ácida o alcalina...
no importa.
Las fuentes hidrotermales son una morada fabulosa para la vida en la Tierra.
¿Qué pasa con Encélado?
Bueno, creemos, porque cuenta con agua
y la ha tenido por un período de tiempo significativo,
y creemos que tiene fuentes hidrotermales
quizá con el material orgánico adecuado,
es un lugar donde la vida podría existir.
Y no solo microbiana;
quizá es más compleja porque tuvo tiempo de evolucionar.
Otra luna, muy similar,
es Europa.
Galileo visitó el sistema de Júpiter en 1996
e hizo observaciones fabulosas de Europa.
Europa, también sabemos, tiene una corteza oceánica bajo el hielo.
La misión Galileo nos dijo eso, pero nunca vimos penachos.
Pero no los buscamos.
El Hubble,
hace solo un par de años,
observando Europa,
vio penachos de agua
pulverizados desde las grietas en el hemisferio sur,
al igual que Encélado.
Estas lunas,
que no están en lo que llamamos una zona habitable tradicional,
que están fuera del sistema solar,
tienen agua líquida.
Y si hay allí orgánicos,
puede haber vida.
Son unos descubrimientos fabulosos
porque estas lunas han estado en un ambiente como ese
durante miles de millones de años.
La vida comenzó en la Tierra, a nuestro juicio, tras los primeros 500 millones,
y miren dónde estamos.
Estas lunas son fabulosos.
Otra luna que estamos viendo es Titán.
Titán es una gran luna de Saturno.
Es quizá es mucho más grande que el planeta Mercurio.
Cuenta con una extensa atmósfera.
Es tan extensa
-- y es en su mayoría de nitrógeno con un poco de metano y etano --
que uno tiene que mirar a través de ella con el radar.
Y en la superficie, Cassini ha encontrado líquido.
Vemos lagos
casi del tamaño de nuestro Mar Negro en algunos lugares.
Y esta zona no es agua en estado líquido;
es metano.
Si hay algún lugar en el sistema solar donde la vida no es como nosotros,
donde el sustituto del agua es otro solvente
-- y podría ser metano --
podría ser Titán.
Bueno, ¿hay vida fuera de la Tierra en el sistema solar?
Todavía no lo sabemos,
pero estamos en la búsqueda activa.
Los datos que estamos recibiendo son muy emocionantes
y nos dicen...
que nos obliga a pensar en esto en formas nuevas y emocionantes.
Creo que estamos en el camino correcto.
Que en los próximos 10 años, responderemos esa pregunta.
Y si la respondemos,
y es positiva,
entonces la vida está en todas partes en el sistema solar.
Basta con pensar en eso.
Podemos no estar solos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)